so thank you all for coming we are very
very fortunate to have Katie K and
Claire Shipman here to talk about their
book the confidence code and we're also
very fortunate to have our own Alondra
Nelson helped to moderate this and
there'll be questions and answers
afterwards let me just say a couple of
things I think of this is it's obviously
an incredibly important problem set of
problems nationally and globally that is
how do we make a world in which women
feel and are able to succeed if you
think of most of the issues in the world
they can be linked back very quickly to
the opportunities for women and this is
something that we've taken very
seriously here at Columbia both in our
own structure as an institution and in
our efforts to try to engage with these
issues around the world
to have two of the leading journalists
in the world to talk about this their
own careers of course very very
successful and to come together and to
write this book to try to understand why
it is that on so many facts it looks
like there ought to be parity in success
in the world and leadership and all
kinds of ways and yet there's not and to
try to understand that is a really
really important effort and we want to
be part of it
so caddy KO courses the anchor for BBC
World News America and she has covered
wars in Kosovo and Afghanistan and Iraq
she's a regular guest on programs like
Meet the Press has travel lived around
the world and was
at Oxford study studying Modern
Languages Claire Shipman is really our
own as an alumna of the institution also
a trustee received her undergraduate and
graduate a degree in Russian studies a
contributor to Good Morning America
World News Tonight and other national
broadcasts news she has built up an
extraordinary journalistic record of
very very significant interviews with
significant people served as the White
House correspondent for NBC News and 10
years at CNN where she covered the fall
of the Soviet Union and as part of the
Moscow Bureau
Alondra Nelson is our Dean of Social
Sciences in the Faculty Arts and
Sciences a professor of sociology and
Gender Studies her interest range from
science and technology to medicine and
health and social movements so thank you
all for being here thank you
so thank you all for coming to join us
for this conversation this evening Thank
You president Bollinger for that
introduction and to Clare and Katie
welcome and thank you very much
so I wanted to begin with the title of
the book which is the confidence code
the science and art of self assurance
what women should know so what is the
confidence code and are you thinking
about tomorrow from the language of
computing are you recommending that we
break the code or write the code well I
think I think a little bit of both I
think that we we think women need to
crack the code to learn the code because
we we set out to discover whether in
fact there is a code and we found that
there are some things we can learn about
confidence and that many of us don't
know but along the way and I would say
it was well into our research where we
realized that the confidence may in fact
not look the same way for everybody that
there may be a way that women need to
take this code and transform it a little
bit for ourselves so I would say both we
called it the science and the art of
self assurance because confidence is
part science we discovered it is partly
genetic there are some people who you
know those slightly annoying people who
seem to kind of drift through life and
everything seems to go swimmingly and
they never shirk at any challenge they
may be born more confident they may
actually have in their DNA genes which
predispose them to being confident so
there's a scientific element to
confidence but there is also an art and
that is the interpretation as Claire
were suggesting of how you manifest your
confidence and I think sometimes for
women that can mean something different
from that image of confidence being kind
of bravado and swagger and the person
that dominates every meeting which
perhaps is what we had thought
confidence was when we set out to write
the book and then discovered it was
something else so you make a pretty
compelling argument in the book that
there's a confidence gap between men and
women so what's the argument or what's
the how do you support this do you want
to share a build but how you support
that and how it manifests itself in the
world this gap well we you know
originally caddy and I came we were left
with this nagging thought from a
different book we wrote five years ago
called Womenomics and here was really
about women in the workplace and and a
lot of very interesting data there but
there was one piece of the puzzle that
we walked away with and we hadn't really
been able to address it in the book and
that was the fact that so many of the
most successful articulate smart
brilliant women we had interviewed would
say things to us like I'm about to get a
promotion but I don't think I'm
qualified my boss wants me to do this I
don't think I'm ready we would hear the
f-word a lot
fraud and a lot more than we thought we
would from the the women who on the face
of it were just incredibly successful
and confident and so we well know clay
used to say she was just in the right
place at the right time right place at
the right if you've ever been sick
exactly it's so true
I went so we stood we thought what is
this just something women talk about or
is there data and we were frankly
surprised to find that there is a lot of
data yeah it's pretty compelling the
evidence that there is a gap in
confidence
among women in the professional space
much less in our relationships we
actually are as confident if not more
confident than men when it comes to our
friendships when it comes to our role as
mothers when it comes to our marriages
and our relationships but when we get
into that professional world
hewlett-packard has done work on this
women will apply for a promotion when
they have a hundred percent of the
skills necessary for the job men are
happy to apply for the same promotion
when they have 60 percent of the skills
because they figure guess what they'll
learn the rest when they get there
Columbia has done work on there's
something called honest overconfidence
which suggests that men tend to
overestimate their abilities by
something like 30% women tend to
underestimate their abilities and that's
really what the confidence gap is it's
that women's perception of their
abilities skews lower than their actual
abilities and we need to shift that
needle to bring it in line with reality
one of the most interesting people we
interviewed is a he's a scientist and he
studies confidence in rats at Cold
Spring Harbor there are apparently
confident and unconfident right yes we
did not know
this when we set up but there are and he
said he the way he views it he tried to
just boil it down to the most basic
level he said his view is that
confidence should serve as a sort of
barometer or a navigation tool for our
lives and it should be ideally as
accurately tuned as possible and in law
is in line with our abilities as
possible and what we came to see is that
for women is just routinely off we're
just not estimating our abilities
accurately most of the time and that can
lead you can imagine over the course of
a career if you're not if you don't
think you're ready for a promotion you
don't think the papers are ready to be
turned in you know right exactly you're
not ready you're not ready yeah yeah so
what do you think the origins are for
the gap I mean there's the art and the
science maybe it's a little bit genetics
maybe it's our rat nature we did one we
did a lot of research for this book we
interviewed dozens of psychologists and
neuroscientists and people in the
business world and one of the bookend
studies that we came across was one done
by a professor in the University of
Milan in Italy a guy called Zach s T's
Zack s T's put a group of men and women
in front of something called a spatial
awareness test it's it looks a bit like
a 3d Rubik's Cube and he asked them to
solve a whole load of problems he found
when he did this test that the women
scored much less well than the men so he
went back over the answers and he also
found when he looked into it that what
was happening was that the women were
skipping questions a lot more often than
the men were he went back to the group
and he said ok no more skipping you all
have to answer all of the questions when
the women had to answer all of the
questions guess what happened they did
just as well as the men did they had
chosen to skip the questions because
they didn't want to risk getting them
wrong and to some extent that became a
metaphor for us about the confidence gap
if you skip the questions in life you
are not going to score as well as you
could do and when we asked Zach s T's so
why is this why
knowing that they would get lower scores
why did the women choose to skip the
questions he said it was that there's
this fear of failure they didn't want to
risk answering something that they
weren't a hundred percent sure they were
going to get right and that that
research was so critical for us because
it came at about the same time that we
finally literally after I think it took
us a year to define confidence okay I
don't think anybody in academia will be
surprised that when Cathy and I set out
to get a definition for confidence that
it wasn't that easy but when this was
first clusterings have a lot of
different opinions about her beliefs the
one we walked away with in the end came
from a professor at Ohio State and he
said to us look at its most basic
confidence is the stuff that turns our
thoughts into action in effect it
greases the wheels for action and we've
never thought about it like that I mean
I think we thought more about confidence
is just a little more closely related to
self-esteem a feeling something that
makes us feel good but for women
especially that action component is very
important because as we will discuss
later but women are we're really good at
thinking and we think and we think and
we think and sometimes we overthink but
sometimes we pause before we act and I
think again the skipping the questions
that tie taking risks we also found that
the action the the process of acting of
taking a risk may be failing struggling
and eventually mastering something
that's the process that creates
confidence so it's really almost a
virtuous circle it gives you know you
act you build confidence and you know it
all leads to and comes back to action so
you're suggesting that confidence is a
part in action is that the only origin
of it I mean are there other places are
there things about the family about the
socialization of girls or there were
there other theories for the origins of
yeah of course that there are ways we
nurture girls and boys from a very young
age that tends to be different not just
us as parents but it happens in
elementary schools there's
we encourage inadvertently I think girls
to be more perfectionist and to take
fewer risk and to screw up less I mean
what busy teacher in a classroom doesn't
want to know that they can rely on some
group to color in the lines and be
respectful and be quiet and not screw up
and raise their hands when they've
perfectly formulated the question or the
answer and because girls have some brain
capacities that make it easier for them
to do that we are very good at Reading
Room's and we have high EQ we're
empathetic like that we do it more
naturally and then we get rewarded for
doing it because we get praised for
doing it what a good girl you are
and then we Karen it sets off a circle
and there's nothing wrong with being
good except for when it means that we
are holding ourselves back and keeping
our voices quiet and when we get out
into the real world you have to be able
to rock the boat a little bit so I think
you know it's a combination of fact as
there are lots of things that go into
starting at a young age into feeding a
process that tends to lead to this
confidence gap well we should also say
that we did find as Katie mentioned that
there is a good bit of science behind
confidence that there's some there's
genetics there we didn't think we
decided we would dive into the science
thinking we've got to do it everybody's
talking about what's genetic what's not
interest science than they're trying to
personality let's look at it but I don't
we did not think we were gonna find that
confidence is genetic and almost
everybody we talked to agreed that some
portion of confidence is in fact
hereditary the estimate they estimate
between 25 to 50 percent now is there a
confidence gene that men have and women
don't that's what we we were worried
about no there's not but there are a
number of genes now that scientists once
the scientists at NIH who's been
studying monkeys for 20 years or other
scientists out in Los Angeles who's
worked on oxytocin I mean that there's a
number of G
and that have a certain variant that is
that contributes to confidence depending
on what variety of that gene you have in
their genes that affect the
neurotransmitters in our brain that
control serotonin for example or
dopamine or oxytocin and that's only
mean that's what we know right now I'm
sure all the scientists in this room
know in another two years we will know a
lot more than we know now but that was
striking to us to discover that some
people probably are born with a more
natural basis for calm feel Andra this
is when Claire had the brilliant idea
that she and I should have our genes
tested writing this book and I kind of
in a slightly sort of distracted moment
said yeah that's fine whatever Claire
let's do it
and it's totally easy to get your genes
tested they send you a little packet and
you spit into a tube and then you send
that tube off by FedEx and then you
spend two weeks sweating while you wait
for the results and it's a bit like
waiting for your SAT results but this is
your whole personality that's on the
line here and what happens if your genes
come back and they're not the genes you
expect it or you're not perfect which of
course we should have been able to
control our genes naturally and we spent
two weeks and finally the neuroscientist
came back with our results and neither
Claire nor I are predisposed to
confidence we're actually basket cases
pretty much on the genetic front and
we've sort of looked at each other we're
either puzzled and thought well what do
we do with this information in terms of
the book yeah and I think what it made
us realize was that although the numbers
are right that it's something like 25 to
50 percent genetic there's a whole big
chunk that isn't yes and that's what
psychologists call volitional the
choices that you make in life and Claire
and I have become confident people but
we've done it despite our genes we've
done it because of the confident the
choices that we have made that's
increased our to a confident right and
I'm just gonna say that and there's of
course it's it's so complex I mean the
interaction of society and our
upbringing in the genes and all of that
together and so we're boiling it down
here
but but it is true that the other part
of the science we found so compelling is
what Kathy was just talking about which
is that brain plasticity and so when
you're talking about volitional or our
ability to affect things now what's so
exciting about the science is you can
see that happening right you can see the
way we can rewire our brains to some
extent with the studies they've done
with PTSD and meditation and the ability
to shrink your amygdala with the fear
center of your brain with just basic
cognitive behavioral therapy techniques
it's really exciting I'm glad you raised
that because I was going to mention that
that you raised the issue of blame brain
plasticity in the book in part because
it you know there's the the genetic
studies leave you sort of in a bit of a
corner and you know how like you know
I'm sort of stuck with this and you know
I got my 25% confidence and you know
what do I do with it cool into a hole
what's fascinating about the book is
that there's you offer a lot of sort of
possibilities actually there's sort of
we identified you identify the gap and
then you say confidence can be built you
know that like the brain our brains are
plastic our behaviors are plastic so do
you can you say a little bit about about
how you build one builds confidence
broadly speaking it kind of divides into
two categories one is we need to act
more which means being prepared to take
risks go outside your comfort zone do
things that you find hard for yourself
because that's how you grow your
confidence I read the news every evening
two millions people around the world
it doesn't actually challenge my
confidence because I've done it so many
times that I know I can do it inside my
comfort zone I would be terrified of
doing your job I would have no idea that
I could do it
the only way I would ever find out would
be trying so it can be as simple as you
go to a party there's an interesting
looking stranger across the room you'd
like to introduce yourself but you're
worried you'll be rebuffed the only way
you'll ever expand your confidence is by
walking across the room and introducing
yourself whether it's in your personal
life in your professional life in your
Emma Clive we grow our confidence by
trying things that are difficult for us
I'll talk about the app mode
Claire can talk about the thinking less
we I went recently to the White House I
was invited to a meeting on on the
Middle East on policy I walk into this
meeting there are 14 men and two women
as so often happens and the National
Security Council and I walk in and I
have that F feeling the fraud feeling
that these are all SuperDuper experts
and they all speak Arabic or Farsi and
they know the policy inside-out and what
am I doing there I'm only a generalist
and really I shouldn't be there and they
get beyond the presentation they get to
the question-and-answer portion of this
session and the men all race actually
they don't even raise their hands they
just jump in with questions and I'm
sitting there thinking you know I really
must ask a question there's only two
women in a room and it would be you know
a disgrace if one of us doesn't ask a
question but if I do then I'll blush and
I'll probably stumble and maybe I'll
stutter and then I'll sweat and they'll
all realize that I don't know what I'm
talking about and all of this is going
on in my head when of course actually
would have been better to listen to the
discussion that would be a lot more
useful I would have learned a lot more
eventually I forced myself to raise my
hand and get the question out and the
sky doesn't fall on my head and the
earth doesn't swallow me whole and it
wasn't the most intelligent question in
the history questions but it wasn't the
most stupid either
and what I realized was that the next
time I was in that situation I knew I
could do it
I had banked confidence I had tried
something that was hard for me I had
gone outside my comfort zone I had taken
a risk and I had succeeded I'd overcome
the hurdles that's how you grow
confidence you take risks and you keep
going and you overcome hurdles and you
master something and I think for women
it's the risk-taking is especially
important because we you know as caddy
talked about earlier we girls and young
women often find themselves becoming
perfectionist when they don't didn't
even set out to be that but that usually
means we're we're not learning to take
risks and fail and so and the other
thing we found is that although the
genetics don't say anything about gender
differences in confidence that there is
a lot of interesting research now about
the way
our brains work male and female brains
and there are some important differences
I'm sure there are a lot of different
opinions about how critical those
differences are but suffice it to say
for example it's it's been studied for
years the fact that women tend to
ruminate more than men do think and
think and overthink and testosterone I
should say has a heavy influence on the
brain in terms of risk-taking women
don't have as much testosterone but but
the rumination is is really key and it
can kill confidence my most embarrassing
but now I'm used to sharing it see I've
built my confidence sharing this
anecdote rumination example came a
couple of months ago when our book was
coming out and I still working for ABC
News tend to feel very guilty when I'm
working on another project and I'm not
working and I think everybody at unist
email Diane Sawyer telling her this
thing I'm working on is gonna be coming
soon and I don't hear back from her and
within two hours I'm obsessively
thinking that she must be incredibly mad
at me because I'm working on my book and
I haven't been doing this and then
within four hours having not heard back
I'm ruminating about whether everybody
at ABC News is actually mad at me at
that point and they all do and then by
the next day I think I should call my
agent because I probably won't have a
job anymore and another day or two and
and it just and you can see how that I
mean I couldn't get any work done it's
interesting we the the fix for it is is
fascinating though because there's so
much research on just basic cognitive
behavioral therapy techniques you can
use to stop that and and for me this has
been such a key because I'm a real
obsessive thinker all you have to do is
come up with any alternative explanation
to whatever your is going on in your
head and it will stop the process so
just for example Diane Sawyer just got
back from Africa of course she's not
going to email me back tonight or the
broadcast is in two hours or she usually
emails me back on the weekends and what
I love about this research is that it
doesn't even have to be a reasonable
explanation
it's that you're giving yourself it does
not it's it's anything will do because
it stops yes the process and the
research on this is fascinating and it
and we have I mean both of us have been
using this and it really is a difference
between men and women I think that men
do seem to be much better at letting
things roll off their back they will
have an upset or a criticism or
something will go wrong will they'll
have a Rao at work or with a friend and
it suddenly just goes and we cling and
we're like dogs with a burn you know we
cling to it those little things yeah so
there's so the confidence gap isn't part
of perfectionism gap and part of the
rumination gap there's a other sorts of
things that are part of it that's
interesting okay so I wanted to sow
confidence I'm I'm compelled that it's a
good thing talk about the difference
between confidence and being bossy right
so in recent weeks there was a study
some behavioral science research from
the new lab at Northeastern University
they used 14 million student evaluation
data points and surprise surprise women
faculty members are more likely than
their male counterparts to beacon called
because called bossy a similar study of
Technology workplaces found that women
are more likely to be called aggressive
and abrasive and their performance
reviews
so is there relationship between these
studies would suggest that women in
leadership roles or women you might say
you are taking risks may be viewed in a
negative light and your investigations
of the confidence gap how do we is that
part of this visit account in part for
the gap actually right there a penalty
for taking the risk there you know there
are dozens of studies in academia and in
corporate life that show that when women
behave just as men do they tend to get
penalized for it we men are seen as good
leaders we are seen as overly aggressive
or overly assertive and we wrestled with
this a lot while we were writing the
book and basically it was the question
was do you have to be a jerk to be
confident and that was kind of how it
seems I think to a lot of women do we
have to have that swagger and dominate
every meeting and have that bravado and
we interviewed for the book Christine
Lagarde who is the first
male head of the International Monetary
Fund and she really helped us with this
and her advice was the important thing
for women and it doesn't totally get
over the issue but the important thing
for women is to be authentic and it's
when women try to behave like men that
we are particularly susceptible to being
seen as a negative light and if you
actually think about it it's very hard
to be confident anyway when you're
putting on somebody else's armor when
you're when you're doing something that
is not inherently natural to you or to
your personality or behaving in a manner
which is not natural to your personality
you feel slightly out of place I mean
you just do and we look the women in the
audience who remember the 1980s when we
wore hideous shoulder pads a little
stream but and it just didn't work right
I mean it was a terrible did not
increase our and I think to some extent
yeah I think about Christine Lagarde who
is one of the most confident and
competent and this is another issue we
raised in there were competence and
confidence women we interviewed and the
thing that you would say about her is
that she's very warm and accessible and
there is something I think in the
qualities that women bring to the table
which makes us useful our ability to
listen our ability to build consensus
our ability to read rooms and and and
have a strong emotional intelligence
those are qualities we don't want to
sacrifice in pursuit of behaving in a
certain manner that's not really
confidence confidence is just
recognizing our abilities for what they
are mean as Claire said you know
bringing that needle in line with our
actual abilities and when you do that
you don't need to project a certain
manner that seems foreign to yourself I
will also say that I think Kerry and I
have come to see as we've been we've
talked to a lot of people since the book
came out a lot of companies and
enterprises and corporations and what's
become clear to us although we you know
we knew it as we ended
the book but is that the the biggest
challenge here is not that people people
who control universities or corporations
or whatever that they don't want things
to change they do and they get this for
all the right reasons but the we still
have to broaden the definition of
leadership and what it looks like and
until that really happens you will have
yes sometimes women might naturally
operate in a more aggressive style that
might be their authentic confidence they
might be penalized women might naturally
be a cop they might be more confident at
listening and analyzing maybe they're
gonna get passed over because they don't
seem I mean and so until we really value
and broaden what a leader looks like we
are going to keep bumping into these
things but I think the more transparent
we can be in discussions like this and
really talking about what it means we're
educating people and that's the most
useful thing we can do so you've talked
to a lot of academics and written
writing this book and you know that we
like to make things very complicated so
I'm just gonna have a sort of
complicated question to a Columbia
alumna and a parent of a Columbia a
first-year student so you you might know
that students faculty and administrators
at Barnard are engaged in important
conversations about whether transgender
women women designated not designated
when female at Birth should be admitted
to this traditionally female college so
I guess the question I wanted to get you
to reckon with because the book provides
advice for women is about just sort of
think about the category of women and
what woman encompasses and think about
it as encompassing a variety of
experiences and identities and with this
in mind how should we think about the
insights and tools that you provide in
your book if we think about women as a
kind of spectrum of experiences and
identity well look I think that you know
to some extent it's funny because we at
one point we sat down with a group of
who shall remain nameless but a group of
very powerful male leaders in a certain
field and they were looking to figure
out how to change things that their
their company and they were frustrated
they hadn't been able to make changes
and and what and when we were talking
about some management changes that might
help women there and and actually one of
the women and one of the men talked
about well we don't we don't want to be
singled out as anything special we don't
want these that's that sort of change
and we said but the fact is when you're
looking at at management changes that
might help increase confidence in women
you're actually looking at changes that
will help everybody across a spectrum
because there are there are men who are
going to benefit from a different kind
of feedback there are there may be women
who don't need that and so in fact what
we're talking about and what we've been
talking about subsequently is just good
management yeah for example and I think
in the in the same way when we're
looking at what how does one manifest
confidence what will work for men or for
women it's of course it's all on a
spectrum we are generalizing really by
need I mean some of it makes sense and
the stereotypes often makes sense for
women but I think when we look at a lot
of this information is going to be
useful to everybody it's not really men
or women I mean don't you think yeah and
I think the other thing I would say
about confidence and we have found it
with women is that women tend to feel a
deficit of confidence particularly in
situations in which they're in the
minority much more so than when we're in
groups of women now whatever minority
you are in and if you're transgender you
are in a minority much smaller minority
it's going to impact your confidence but
Claire and I are routinely on political
panels where we are the only woman it
doesn't feel great for your confidence
so that wall of stereotype threat or
whatever you want to call it impostor
syndrome is is true for everyone who
feels themselves in a minority great so
another question I guess about what
keeps staying on campus a bit what would
you recommend for students and for young
women across the spectrum in particular
because you know
the christine lagarde example is
wonderful but she's christian oh so what
about when she was little Christina card
I mean her great story about a Christian
I guard at the age of four used to
babysit her younger siblings and she had
proved yoots this experience to some of
her confidence okay the fact that she
was stretched and put in this position
which my daughter Maya has babysat her
siblings I don't think ever at the age
of four right my even I would not have
pushed it that far although it would've
been cheap I mean that would be great
and she does say that it was being put
in a position where she was always made
to believe that she could do things and
so she was put in these positions of
responsibility and she did I don't see
one thing I would say and this is
something we have looked at has been
quite a lot of work has been done on
this woman's are doing incredibly well
as you all know academically with
superstars right we are getting more
degrees than men are we're getting more
postgraduate degrees we're getting more
PhDs than men are then we're getting
into the professional world and
something changes we aren't doing as
well as that academic promise suggests
we should do and I thought was that
somewhere between the world of academia
and this fabulous campus and the
professional worlds you are about to
enter the rules change and what serves
you so well here is not necessarily what
is going to get you ahead in the
professional world I can tell you having
been there for the last thirty years
it's a much more political space you
need to be able to talk about your
successes promote yourself you need to
be able to make alliances and networks
you need to rock the boat being a good
girl all the time is not going to get
you ahead at work and I think equipping
our young women in the actus I think it
comes as a real shock for young women
what happened I was a superstar and now
I look at this professional space and
I'm not sure I'm gonna get ahead in it
and I think that's what happens
somewhere the rules change and we don't
play so well and the more we can equip
our young women to realize that those
rules are going to change and to realize
what they're going to need to do the
more we can help them get as far as they
should
good to go this is such a terrific
opportunity for young women to
experiment with risk-taking and failure
and I know that sounds horribly
frightening for all of the women in the
audience because straight you know
certainly if you're here you probably
haven't failed that much but again yet
you know that's what it is for young
women to start to understand that
failure is part of success and that this
is the place where you can most learn
with such freedom the lessons of taking
a risk and taking a chance and doing
things you don't know how to do very
well because you are gonna be required
to do that later in life so we just have
a few more moments so the last question
I wanted to ask about your partnership
as collaborators though you've written
over the last decade two books together
the confidence code and women ah mcc's
which you referred to and so I just
wanted to ask you about that friendship
that that you know that collaboration
the kind of rich productive partnership
you've had and how that's contributed to
the work that you've been doing for
others I don't know I'm not sure we
would have gotten a book done I think
Stephen Colbert joked with us at one
point and said why did it take two of
you to write over my new women were
worse at all of those two to get this
done if you each have 50% of the
confidence we we certainly motivate each
other and I think we realized very early
on that we were going to work well
together and that if so many people
warned us against rights actually they
said everyone to that don't do this with
a friend your friendship will end it
will be an utter devastating to each
other again
but we found that we we both put the
work first if we actually managed to to
keep to a large extent egos out of it
and I think that's something else women
are able to do well and it means that we
can we can just get more done together
and it's terrific and it's gosh it means
our husbands don't have to listen to
quite as much
waiting for a chapter you kind of have
to work on it it was a very good
motivator get the ability right
otherwise we'd have sat and stared out
the window and you know made another cup
of tea and never have got done yeah but
it's I mean it to the point where we
really we were so it was such a great
experience the first time we really
decided we wanted to work together again
right and we do it again yes yeah
something yes yeah wonderful so we have
about 15 minutes for questions there's a
microphones in the aisles here and
president Bollinger is gonna help us
with the QA so if you just stand up at
the microphones and state your name and
your question but let me begin with a
question I'm I'm curious what you think
about sort of the the social movements I
mean you can think about this as you
have in a very sophisticated way as the
things that women need to do to increase
their confidence and their success in
their own terms and and then there's of
course changing the world in which we
all live and we've seen cycles in civil
rights and passages of laws over time
and I would say you know we're at not
one of the stronger periods of real deep
social movements to try to address the
changes in society that need to happen
in order for all kinds of greater
equality across the board so I mean my
view is you know we would benefit from a
new civil rights movement for example so
as you think about this from the angle
that you've come what are your
reflections on social movements to
change the the world in which we're all
living to make it a fair just they're
more just world it would be Pollyannish
to suggest that just by closing the
confidence gap we could suddenly level
the playing field between men and women
we still know that there is not equal
pay for equal work there is still a
lamentable lack of maternity leave for
women here in the United States there
are things that need to be done that can
only be done with jealousy there will
not at an individual level but we need
more women I think in positions of
influence to affect those policies we
need more than a fifth of the Senate to
be women and if a lack of confidence is
one of the things that is holding women
back from getting to the top to affect
those policy changes then it is
something that is useful to address
right it's not going to in and of itself
level that playing field instantly I
think that it um it's funny I do that
because we get typically and and I know
we'll have some questions but some of
the questions we often get are about
from from younger women especially who
are so eager to learn and and often
perfectionists and good at getting
everything right you know how can i
navigate my what if I'm going to be seen
as too aggressive what if I'm going to
do this what if I how do I act exactly
the right way and I finally started
saying and I and I think this is when
you start to talk to younger women about
the fact that it's not all going to work
out you're probably going to ruffle some
feathers and you're gonna have to do
that to try to create change for the
people coming behind you and and that
that's actually been motivational I've
seen that that people are kept people
connect to that and I've also seen a lot
more in the past year or two than when
we at five years ago when we wrote
Womenomics that women wanting to create
change for other women older women
wanting to create change wanting to
really make something happen there's a
lot more passion for that now and
even come to the conclusion for my
daughter who I mean I have to say she's
nine years old and I for years I feel
like I was hiding things from her about
the way the world is because I realized
I was embarrassed that there's not a
female on that presidential placemat or
that there's not and I didn't know I
didn't really want to tell her and now I
realized that actually I the more I can
inspire her with the work we need to get
done and some of the reality that she's
feeling motivated by that too and so I
think that I just think hey if we can
use little things like talking about
confidence and other things to get
people engaged in yeah in the larger
work so there's a site for time there's
a cycle that plays out that's very
interesting yes please my name is
Jessica and I just want to start by
thanking you I absolutely loved your
book and I have found myself stepping up
as I am right now more frequently since
reading it so I want to say thank you
for that this question comes from a
woman who doesn't identify as nurturing
and it gets called bossy more frequently
than I would like I'm wondering if by
calling attention when you say things
like women are nurturing women are
perceptive I'm not particularly
perceptive I'm more analytical and so
I'm wondering kind of those statements
can be powerful in bringing you know
attention to the issue but I'm wondering
if you're finding that that could
actually reinforce stereotypes in the
workplace some of the the reasons we
talk about women being perceptive and
good at assimilating rooms and reading
body language for example actually have
a Genesis in brain differences between
men and women that there are more
neurons firing for example at any one
time in a woman's brain than there are
in a man's brain it's the kind of thing
that makes us very good at multitasking
it's on the flip side it's also the kind
of thing that does lead to us ruminating
more and
more but it is a quality that makes us
able to read people's emotions because
we have these brain differences so I
don't think that I think for too long
the skills that women have that were
seen as soft skills were slightly
denigrated or not valued actually now
what we are finding in the corporate
world anyway is that those skills can be
profitable skills can be incredibly
valuable skills particularly when you
have a mixture of leadership capacities
when you have people some people who are
good at Reading Room's some people are
not good some people who are bossy some
people who are less bossy what you want
the ideal combination is a mixture it
doesn't really matter whether they're
men or women it just matters that you
have that mixture so I think it's I I
would tend to err on having been in the
workforce for now thirty years and
having spent a long time when I first
entered the workforce thinking oh all
those things that I'm good at
relationship building communicating
understanding people listening to people
all of those things aren't really very
valuable I think it's great that we can
celebrate that they are valuable
finally it's okay to say we're different
but I think it's also important to
understand that really what matters in
any decision-making process whether it's
in politics or in journalism and
business or the military we're in sports
is a mixture of opinions and and
capacities and that's what we're aiming
for
so let me make a suggestion because I'm
worried that we're going to run out of
time and there are a number of people
who would like to ask questions so I
would suggest that you ask the question
next person will take three or four and
then you can decide how to answer them
is that good I think that way we'll make
sure that we allow people to hi my name
is Susan Strasser I'm from the School of
Public Health and uptown and my question
is about our children I have two
daughters ones 23 and ones 13 and my
younger daughter said something years
ago when she was about six that actually
took my breath away and I thought I was
doing things right I was and I was
always working when the children were
growing and trying to have that balance
that work-life balance they saw me as a
leader in my job I directed a country
program I was getting my PhD and I
thought I was showing them what women
can do and be and what took my breath
away was one day I went upstairs and got
it one of my other daughters books
brought it down for her to look at it
and it was a book about Hillary Clinton
and she said well who is this it was a
story book about Hillary Clinton's like
a biography and I said she's a woman I
think might be president one day and she
said but how can she be president she's
a woman and this was a six year old girl
who had a mother who had always been in
the work world always in trying to be a
leader in in her work and that really
shocked me and that is such a young
child could have that perception and and
how do we change that thank you
yes my name is Megan and I'm a graduate
student in information and knowledge
strategy so my question is I once
applied for a job and it was very much
centered on data analytics they asked me
if I had experience working with pivot
tables
I understand pivot tables but I didn't
and I
kind of just said well I'm eager to
learn and I told this to a male
counterpart who told me well just
YouTube it I would have told him I was
an expert I was like well yeah maybe but
I guess my question is for those of us
who are coming out of school we may not
have a lot of experience in the
workforce how do we sell our potential
to accomplish things that we know that
we're capable of doing to people who
expect that we've already done them
thank you very much we take one more and
then hi my name is Jacqueline I'm a
visiting graduate student with semester
at Columbia and I have a two-part
question but it's very concrete the
first part is we were told that there
are two aspects and I know I'm totally
being perfectionistic when I say this
two aspects and one of them was to take
more risks and that's what you were
saying and then I kind of was waiting
for the whole rest of the talk so to see
what's the other aspect so that's the
first part and the second part is I
don't usually ask questions like I took
a risk in doing this today because it
feels like a risky day because I just
started a new job today
and I figure why not but my question is
it seems from what you're saying that
women are more accurate in being self
reporters of their own confidence and
that so that translates to me as women
being more accurate so it's not that
women are not confident enough it's that
men are actually overconfident and I
don't mean that as a joke I mean it as
somebody who's studied like
neuropsychology etc I was a psych majors
and undergrad and so my question is
instead of seeing that as a deficit is
there a way we can change within
leadership within the work world just
the definition of you know what we think
of as confidence so that you know a
six-year-old doesn't say well she's a
woman how can she be president great and
we'll actually take one more so we make
sure that we
snick Dunkley work in the Arts and
Sciences Department I'm actually curious
about your research on if it's has
actually came up on generational changes
and challenges I am you know from
Jamaica and you know pushing through
from my mom's kind of experiences and
breaking through certain barriers was a
big deal but then when I came to America
it was sort of there was still more to
go so I'm just really curious about you
know kind of what your research showed
you want sort of pushing that envelope
from a generational point of view so we
got four questions what was the fifth
question yeah so young six year old
thinks well women can't be present a six
year old I could say that I think having
experienced that myself recently with my
daughter it's a but it was now nine look
it's you know they see more than just
they see more than just their parents
right so kids are smart I mean they look
out and they see that you know why would
why would any young girl necessarily
assume a woman would be president we
haven't had one right and so I think
it's it's not necessarily I think we are
incredibly important as role models but
I think we have to be realistic about
what else they're seeing in the world
and and that's what when I was saying I
think we can talk to them about it be
transparent instead of trying to shove
it under the carpet just lay it all out
there and use that as a as a chance for
conversation about what she might be
able to do to change that it's hard to
imagine something you haven't seen you
know especially for a six-year-old
question - I think now for the question
- was about quote selling your potential
in an interview and and how do you do
that which is relate to the third one
which was you know why do I want to be a
jerk I'd rather you know if you tell me
I'm accurate right yeah you know I think
I'd rather be that than this right the
question is on
second bit of that whether women are
being accurate you give women and men
scientific reasoning quest quizzing men
will routinely overestimate how well
they've done women will routinely
underestimate how well they've done
they've actually done the same and
that's the problem the problem is not
the the problem is that we have plenty
of ability and competence we just don't
think we have as much competence and
ability as we actually have and we need
to bring our perception of that ability
in line with our honest ability that's
all we really need to do it's quite
simple and it's not that we want to
pretend to be more confident than we are
or pretend anything we don't want to
fake it till we make it but we don't
either want to routinely go around
thinking we are worse than we are that
is why men are going for promotions when
they have 60% of the skill set and I
think it was pivot theory which they
were understanding and and saying that
they could YouTube it because they
actually realized they can you can do it
too you understand plenty and you can
learn the rest if you recognize your
ability to learn and your intelligence
and your experience and your skills and
your competence
you won't under your self and that's
what we're trying to do in closing the
confidence gap clear well look I think
that I mean it's interesting we do get
that question a lot about all right well
well shouldn't we be trying to make men
less confident and it shouldn't that be
our focus really and then we don't have
to cook and I guess maybe that's her
next book we're not sure this is the
point though I mean it does and actually
all of the psychologists most of the
psychologists who were academics that we
interviewed didn't agree on very much it
doesn't surprise you perhaps but the one
thing they did agree on is that a little
bit of overconfidence is better for all
of us than a little bit of under
confidence because it encourages us to
take action I really want to give the
chance to these three women to ask the
questions but you have to do so very
quickly because we promised that we
would be done by 7:00 and
over that but if you asked very quickly
we'll try to get an answer for you
please go ahead okay my question is
sorry what recommendations do you have
on building your confidence after
failure so if you did raise your arm or
your hand to ask a question and it was a
dumb question how do you recover from
yes please
hello my name is Kelsey thank you for
your talk today I'm a bit of a political
junkie and so caddie my question is
specifically for you and your daily or
week to week experience in on political
news shows I watch you and Meet the
Press on occasion and Morning Joe more
recently and as a not a daily but a
regular Morning Joe watcher I'm
frequently find myself feeling quite
uncomfortable about the issue of
confidence and it's very specifically
gender focused and for those who watch
the show you'll know that Joe
Scarborough is absolutely the type that
was born with every gene possible for
confidence he's got so much of it and
I'm sometimes uncomfortable with the way
that he fills up the space on the show
and everybody I'm just so curious to
hear as as a member on various shows how
do you feel if you're willing to share
about that and what if anything do you
you know apply any strategies when
you're there on the scene thank you one
more please quickly my question is a how
do you differentiate between confidence
and arrogance particularly coming across
that way when navigating politics within
an organization
or navigating politics among other women
there you go it's refile I won't take
the Morning Joe question yeah I took
that I took that for you I've only been
on the show a couple of times
so first of all coming back from failure
I think that the in a the shortest
answer is really to try to once you've
suffered a little bit as we all need to
do and we fail just to try to look at it
as what what can you learn from it I
mean what what are the lessons you can
learn from what has just happened so
that you can move on I mean the key is
to try to as quickly as we can and Jim
Valentini and I were talking about this
earlier think about it as pivoting to
your next experiment your next challenge
and you take what information you have
from that failure which was part of the
learning process and and move on I can't
remember the third question already
arrogance arrogance yes well that was
that is one of the key questions in our
book right how are we confident without
being jerks and I think it's it really
has to do with I think authentic
confidence and that is a real
understanding of you know you you
believe when you have confidence that is
really based on the experiences that you
had stockpiled and what you know you can
do it then it's not bravado it's
actually authentic confidence now of
course there you know confidence there
are many kinds of behavior that lie on
top of confidence and some of the stuff
caddy was talking about earlier about
our ability to read a room our ability
to get along with people I mean all of
that there are ways of delivering
information that are arrogant or not but
pure confidence should not necessarily
be arrogant you can I quickly before I
off the Morning Joe one which I'm still
mulling the generational question which
the young lady asked can't we Clare and
I when we brought the book out did a
confidence assessment that is on our
website the confidence code calm you're
welcome to go and take it
and we are feeding the information from
that assessment back to the academics
who came up with the assessment and won
and they are still going through it all
but one of the headlines is that for
women confidence grows during the course
of our lifetime much more than it does
for men men
seem to be have similar levels of
confidence at the age of 55 to the age
of 25 for women that's definitely an
increase so there is a generational
growth the Morning Joe question the show
is called Morning Joe not morning
anybody else and it is successful
because in part because of the
personality of the host I think
television is an x-ray and it's very
difficult to disguise who you are what
you are and I go into those shows with
things that I think are interesting to
say or points of views that I have but
it would be ridiculous for me to try to
be something I'm not
everyone in the audience would see it
straight away
so I think the way I cope with that show
as I do with any of the shows I'm on
it's just by saying the things and
Claire I'm sure would agree on political
panels saying the things you have to say
I'm talking about what you know about
and what you have opinions on and
avoiding all of the things you don't
have opinions on so Ken Kelly I said at
the beginning you know Claire was our
own and Londoner our own - because
you're a parent and and we really
appreciate that but these are three
wonderful people and we would all be
fortunate in life if we could be as good
as they are thank you very much for
being